[Music]
[Applause]
Megan's body image story started because
she wanted to lose weight from the
get-go I guess you'd say I grew up in a
big body II like I grew up you know what
people I guess
typically caught overweight what made
you decide to lose weight well I had
joined a gym quite innocently with a
friend because she said it was fun so I
was like okay I'll join and I liked the
dynamic of the gym it was a quick
workout sort of thing you know you go
for half an hour and it was quite
friendly this is me I guess you'd say
that's me at my biggest that was
probably my last year of high school and
that's me or some years after in two
years Megan lost 50 kilos and she
started posting about it on Instagram
people looking at this and I had people
that I knew or people that I didn't know
people that were reaching out to me via
the internet telling me that I was
inspiring and I was I was a real
motivator for then what sorts of bodies
were you looking at on Instagram and and
how are they making you feel lots of
toned very lean very that typical what
you would call shredded sort of body I
was certainly trying to do all methods
of training to look like that so yeah
but did you feel like you shouldn't have
that body oh absolutely I thought it
made me a better person
Megan's focus on her body image started
to become the most important thing in
her life
I was exercising every day but then I
started to run and I started to be able
to tackle that 5k distance and then that
wasn't enough so I started to train for
10k events and then before I know it I
trained for a marathon and then I was
training for more marathons so I was
going to the gym but then also running
training on top of that so it sounds
like it was quite addictive like you get
to 5ks and then tain yeah yep always
moving the goalposts on myself the
exercise fixation began to spiral into
something else there was a point where
the obsession tipped over and I started
to notice that I was always thinking
about food whether I was doing the right
thing whether I was doing enough whether
what I had eaten had turned me I'm
healthy again and all this guy I mean
that what I'd eaten had turned me
unhealthy yeah I just got to this point
where I was so focused on health that
had I had one meal or one snack or
something that would I wouldn't have
regularly eaten I would just have his
wave of anxiety that that would send me
backwards and I guess you know put the
weight back on I was really really
fearful of waking up one day and then
realizing oh hang on I've put all my
weight back on Megan's anxieties about
her body began to overwhelm her and her
diet evolved into a series of really
strict rules I was caught up in that
idea of clean eating for me I had made
the decision that anything that was
processed during packets was to be
completely avoided and and it's almost
impossible there were so many decisions
to make and making a decision when all
you can hear is right wrong healthy
unhealthy guilty what good food is and
what bad food is it was just terrifying
it was really overwhelming it was almost
like the actual food on the Shelf was
talking to me
telling me all of its pros and all of
its cons and then the next thing I would
need to go and buy was another voice in
my head
there was one time trying to buy a piece
of steak and the idea of trying to buy a
certain size of steak her certain weight
of steak the decision got soever
whelming that I remember just sort of
blanking out dropping my basket and just
staring for what was about 40 minutes
just 40 40 minutes I knew my
relationship with foods gone beyond
anything that I could I could deal with
myself I needed help from there
Megan consulted several doctors but many
of them praised her for losing weight
and told her to keep running and dieting
still obsessing about her ideal body
image physical symptoms began to appear
[Music]
at your worst point what what were the
symptoms well physically speaking I lots
of pins and needles all the time I had
really little sensation in my hands
especially in my feet I was cold all the
time very tired I was always exhausted
and my hair had fallen out and at the
height of it I had I had a messy
menstrual cycle my menstrual cycle had
gone for about three years it was gone
yeah so did you eventually get diagnosed
with something eventually I started
working with a therapist she admitted
that she had never really spoken with a
patient or a client that had come to her
with these kinds of thoughts and
obsessions and behaviors before and she
did a lot of research on her part and we
realized that I was I was living with an
author I was living with orthorexia or I
was dealing with orthorexia and what
does that mean basically just that this
really unhealthy obsession with health
today
Megan feels much more in control of her
health and has recently had a baby I'm
starting to see that a lot of people
with body image concerns share this
obsessive fixation on their bodies it is
so interesting that a person can look
like the epitome of health they can look
like the best version of themselves the
most healthy the most toned the most fit
version of themselves the type of person
that can run marathons and and lift
weights but it's it's all it's all
surface you know on the inside there
they're obsessive and that they're
unhealthy and they're miserable and I
mean Megan's hair was falling out she
was going numb in her fingers and toes
she was cold all the time she was tired
all the time her periods and stopped you
know there were so many red flags there
about
really bad physical and mental health
but she looks great
[Music]
I want to find out if what's happening
is part of a broader trend professor
Philippa hay has been studying body
image for almost 25 years so I've been
speaking to people who who seem to have
quite serious body image related
problems and I'm wondering if that's
something that you're seeing more and
more of yes indeed some of our research
may be it's been finding that's
increased tenfold or more in the past
decade and Australians tenfold so it's
10 times worse than it used to be
absolutely yes and now around 10 percent
of Australians self-define themselves
that's the most important thing to them
is their body image over their body
shape and weight the muscular shape a
very thin shape that's how they define
themselves and that is more important to
them than anything else in their life so
more important to them than losing a job
or going to something that's really
important in their lives like a wedding
for example or a birthday party who's at
risk of over valuing their body image of
getting to the point where that's the
most important thing for them well we're
all at risk because in our society we
have a positive regard for certain types
of bodies and body image so that
increases everybody's risk so 10 percent
of Australians have this problem that's
that's two and a half million people yes
there's a lot of people and those people
would say are at high risk of having
eating disorder I have a food eating
disorder or other body image disorder
like muscle dysmorphic disorder so
things seem to be moving so fast in this
space and we all just sort of playing
catch-up here to try and help these
people sure we're we've got the big
catch up to play is more generally in
the area of the clinic because in the
clinic those disorders are not well
recognized are not well recognized in
our manual such as DSM which is our
manual for how we diagnose disorders in
fact orthorexia is not even in the DSM
for example so it is it is a major
treatment problem major treatment gap we
have recognition of emerging disorders
like Meghan's orthorexia is important
because acceptance in the clinical
manual can lead to funding for a search
into treatments
[Music]
I didn't really realize the scale of
this problem I didn't realize that there
were two and a half million Australians
who have a really dangerous view of
their body image and thinking about it
to the point where everything else in
their life is taking a complete backseat
all of these new disorders are popping
up and we're not really keeping up with
it
[Music]